[Music]
targaryen cannot be trusted the mad
Kings daughters will destroy the realm
we have an army of fleets and three
dragons we should hit King's Landing now
[Music]
hey everybody time to break this down
also address a couple of the bigger
questions for my episode 1 video and
there's a new round of the giveaway for
HBO now all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video so the first thing
Yan Royce of the Vale is crapping on
Daenerys that means that they may have
gotten the Raven from Samwell telling
them about the dragon glass at
Dragonstone so immediately you know
exactly how Jon Snow is going to react
we need to go get that but most of the
people in this room were old enough to
remember Robert's rebellion so they're
still thinking about the Mad King the
mad Kings daughter will destroy the
realm Cersei says it herself too they're
trying to set Daenerys and her dragons
up as this conquering force that's going
to wash over the realm and destroy
everything
people like Yan Royce his concerns are
valid they have no reason to trust
Daenerys no matter what she's done in
the east all they know is that she's
coming to take the Iron Throne so it's
going to take a leap of faith on their
part in something to prove Daenerys his
intentions so we can lay some
predictions about how that might happen
like they have to prove to Daenerys the
threat of the White Walkers so that
she'll believe Jon Snow in Daenerys is
going to have to do something to make
John Snow and his people believe in her
so we as the audience obviously know
that Jon Snow is part Targaryen so they
very literally share DNA but Jon Snow
doesn't know that Daenerys doesn't know
that and bran isn't anywhere near
Winterfell and there are a lot of
predictions that he is not going to
reveal the entire truth to John this
season like Game of Thrones is really
good at providing visual cues the
dragons might like Jon Snow they might
behave differently around him and that
would be one way of implying that
they're not so bad but Tyrion really I
think is going to be the person to help
here because he spent a lot of time with
Jon Snow at the wall he's turned against
Queen Cersei so just like you're on
allied with Cersei the enemy of my enemy
is my friend Jon Snow has one more
reason to trust them because they hate
Cersei as much as he does so without any
revelation from Brand Daenerys Jon Snow
alliance is just one of convenience like
we need all the help we can get we need
you and your dragonglass right now but
then you have Cersei in the South trying
to drum up more support by striking fear
into the hearts of everyone who isn't
already allied with the north or with
the Targaryen restoration she's going to
come in and just
draw everything that's how you get
people to turn against Daenerys just set
her up as the mad Queen the mad Kings
daughter come again
Cersei is a master at fear-mongering and
twisting people around her finger that's
why I liked the sanso line from the
previous episode where she talks about
how dangerous Cersei is and Jon Snow's
like you sound like you admire her
there's no sign of Jaime Highgarden that
might be pushed to episode 3 but really
the exciting thing is Yara Greyjoy just
jumping the gun we have of belief we
have three dragons let's strike King's
Landing now so there are a couple of
things that are going on in this scene
one you see olaria sand you know that
you're on Greyjoy needs to bring a gift
to Cersei a priceless gift so a lot of
you book readers in the comments we're
asking about Euron's dragon horn from
the books I don't think the TV show is
gonna do the horn I think the priceless
gift will be ilaria Sant they'll battle
at sea Joran will crush Daenerys as
fleep because it's a nice parallel for
Robert's rebellion in Daenerys his birth
which I'll explain in a second I talked
a little bit about it during my episode
1 video they're just setting up this
idea that they're going to balance the
scales because right now Yara is not
wrong they have this unstoppable force
but they're at sea and Euron is the most
powerful person at sea during Robert's
rebellion on the night of Daenerys is
birth there was this great storm raging
above Dragonstone in Blackwater while
the drama of her birth was unfolding the
Targaryen elite was being smashed at sea
so it just sounds like they're going to
parallel that there's a lot of parallels
for Robert's rebellion a lot of
parallels for Aegon's conquest that's
what all those comments from archmaester
Marwan in the Citadel were about jim
broadbent character where he said people
freaked out during Robert's rebellion
they thought the world was ending people
freaked out during Aegon's conquest and
thought the world was ending people
freaked out during the long night in
thought that the world was going to end
and I know a lot of you are asking about
the White Walkers at
eastwatch-by-the-sea like are they just
gonna go around the wall what's the deal
what's the wall for if they just gonna
go around it I think what's going to
happen is is that they can't go around
it but because of brands mark that's
going to leave a little bit of a crack
so if you did have a really big army the
easiest way to move it around the wall
would literally be to go around the wall
but I think what's been
preventing them for doing that before
has been the enchantment something about
the way the night king marked bran has
weakened that but it's going to take a
little bit more so that's where the big
battle is going to take place so just be
aware in these early episodes that they
set up ideas and plot points like the
cat's-paws Valyrian dagger in Sam wells
book that's probably a page about making
Valyrian steel and some of the things
that are required the next big thing
this was kind of spoilery so I didn't
want to put this in the thumbnail but
it's 9 Miriah Aria runs into her on her
way what it looks like South but there's
snow on the ground so something could
happen early in the episode with those
Lannister soldiers or ed sheeran drops
an info bomb that makes her think of her
home say oh no I don't need to go south
I need to go north so she turns around
and goes back north but the last time
Nymeria was seen in the book she was in
the Riverlands there is a super-pac that
she's gathered around her she's still
alive in the books so it was implied
that at some point Arya would have a
reunion with her we just didn't know
when it was gonna happen and how it was
gonna go down and just for reference
while she was in Braavos all that time
that she was studying to be a faceless
person she was still having wolf dreams
all of the star children who are still
alive and whose dire wolves are still
alive which is now just Aria with
Nymeria in Jon Snow with ghost have wolf
dreams and it's because they're wargs
like they have that in their DNA but it
could be Ed Sheeran's group it could be
Nymeria that causes Arya to think about
her home and question her mission to
cross her seas name off of her list
something just reminds her of her home
and that's probably what turns her
around a lot of you are asking about who
this woman stabbing in the trailer is it
looks like she's on one of the ships so
it's probably just from that big Greyjoy
battle but she does not look familiar
you see Yara kissing al arias and I
guess that's maybe to make you care
about the character more before they
have a big twist with Joran and Cersei
we're going to do all kinds of awful
things to you and I know you're all
going crazy about this Jon Snow
throttling Littlefinger in the crypts
they're actually next to the statue of
Lyanna stark so there could be any
number of things that Littlefinger could
say that would piss Jon Snow off but
it's probably just meant to undermine
his leadership there are a lot of people
that are theorizing that Littlefinger
knows Jon Snow's parentage but I don't
think that's the case I think that
Littlefinger suspects things I think
that he knows that Rhaegar was in love
with Lyanna stark but he probably
doesn't have absolute proof of Jon
Snow's parentage so we'll find out next
week but leave all your bonus video
requests in the comments below I'm still
collecting questions for my first Q&A
video for episode 1 so anything that I
haven't mentioned or anything you think
I've left out of the videos I'll try to
include in that I'll name the latest
giveaway winner when I post that that'll
be on Tuesday and a lot of you have
asked to send me stuff in the mail I
don't have a Pio box right now but I'll
try to take care of that and I'll let
everybody know so if you do want to send
me stuff you'll be able to do that
pretty soon but while you wait for
everything click here for my episode 1
video and you can click here for all my
death predictions thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
you